I've got to wrap it up I don't want to
but I have to I want to ask you just
quickly uh the film director Olivia
Wilde is a new movie out which yeah she
says it's based on you this insane man
this pseudo-intellectual hero to the
in-cell community in cell being these
weirdo loner men uh who are despicable
in many ways is that you are you the
intellectual hero to these people
sure why not you know
um
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is
thought the marginalized were supposed
to have a voice
is making emotional talk about well God
you know
it's very difficult to understand
how demoralized people are
and certainly many young men are in that
category and you get these casual
insults these these in cells is what do
they mean it's like well these men
they're they don't know how to make
themselves attractive to women who are
very picky and good for them women like
be picky that's that's your gift man
demand high standards from your man fair
enough but all these men who are
alienated it's like
they're Lonesome and and and they don't
know what to do and everyone piles abuse
on them when she said that Olivia Wilde
it stung you didn't it that's all oh by
that time you know
that as far as as critic critiques go
that was kind of low level I mean once I
got painted as
Red Skull you know magical super Nazi
that was kind of the end of the insults
there's no place past that so when
Olivia Wilde made those comments the
first thing I did was go look at the
preview for a movie which I quite liked
I thought I would go see that movie
probably and perhaps I will it didn't
really bother me my my family and I
talked about it right away and we were
able to respond to it with some degree
of humor which then people completely
misunderstood I said I hope that you
know that if I had to be played by
someone I think Chris Wilde is that
he's a very good looking man and so that
seems all right you know and then I said
something like I hope he gets my my uh
fashion style choice right when he plays
me and it was a joke all that was a joke
you've been so controlled today
and yet in that brief moment you got
very emotional why
it's really something to see
constantly
how many people
are dying for a lack of an encouraging
word
and how easy it is to provide that if
you're careful
you know give credit where credit is due
and to say
you're in that Force for good if you
want to be
do you believe you're not full so good
net yes
in all the details probably not
you know no one's perfect
so
people make their mistakes as they
stumble uphill
Jordan's been a fascinating interview
thank you very much
Eve thank you you've got this new box
set up yeah yeah I'm pretty happy about
that 24 rules for life uh and Beyond
order uh fascinating books they sold how
many millions now well 12 rules sold
seven and I think Beyond order is
approaching a million now so yeah
they're doing just fine you ever think
you'd sell that number of books I never
thought any of this would happen you
know I mean
so yeah I knew when I was teaching at
Harvard and at the University of Toronto
that some of the things I were I was
teaching were revolutionary I was
surprised that I got along with it got
away with it let's say as long as I did
and so there's a way in which it doesn't
surprise me and and I wouldn't say
that's because of the Brilliance of my
ideas it's because I'm I'm good at
communicating ideas but the ideas that
I've been developing their ancient ideas
they're the oldest ideas we have in some
real sense they have a power right
absolutely your uh launched the Peterson
Academy tell me about that quickly yeah
well um I've been collecting along with
my daughter
um great professors and Educators from
all around the world and we're having
them come to Miami to film four two-hour
lectures on a variety of topics um
president of Hillsdale College Larry
Arne just taped one for us on Churchill
which I thought was quite funny because
you know he's Persona non-grata and so
Aaron and Churchill so that's quite
funny and we're hoping that we can
determine how to provide people a very
efficient and very low-cost alternative
to a bachelor's degree and we're working
hard to make that accredited I'd like to
drive the cost of a bachelor's degree
from its current 160 thousand dollar
level to four thousand dollars and I
think I think we can do it so that's the
plan we're going to launch in either
early 2023 depending on how quickly we
can get things aggregated and so and I'm
working with my son on an app called
essay
sa.app it we we took a document I wrote
for my students that helped them learn
how to write and edit so and editing is
very important if you're right and
people are never taught to edit and it
builds editing tools into the software
and we have four forty five hundred
subscribers and 50 000 users we launched
about two months ago I'd like to teach a
million people to write
so and just finally you're healthy you
look healthy
pretty good much better your wife's
doing a lot better than she was
she's back better than she was before
even and my daughter is not ill either
so fancy that I mean that's an amazing
turnaround from where you went that's
for sure man it was pretty
brutal yeah
for a long time yeah you know my wife
almost died every day for seven months
so
I'm very glad for you thank you sir I
really am it's been a really a
fascinating interview